THE ASSEMBLY IS NOW IN SESSION.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BRO NOTICES THE
ABSENCE OF A QUORUM.
THE SERGEANTS ARMS WILL PREPARE
THE CHAMBER IN BRINGING THE
ABSENT MEMBERS AND THE CLERK.
WILL CALL THE ROLL.
ACOSTA.
AGUIAR CURRY.
ALLEN
ARAM BELA.
BAKER.
BERMAN.
BIGELOW.
BLOOM.
BONTA.
BRAVO.
BURKE
CABALLERO.
CALDERONE CORREO SERVAN TEMAS
CHILD. CHAVEZ CAN.
DAVID CHIU. CHOI KANSEN CHU.
COOLEY COOPER. CUNNINGHAM.
SALLY. DAILY.
EGGMAN LARA.
FONG.
FRAZIER. FREEDMAN GALLAGHER
CASINO GARCIA EDUARDO GARCIA.
GIPSON. GLORIA GONZALEZ
FLETCHER.
GRAY.
GRAYSON
HARPER. PULLED THEN.
WHEN JONES SAWYER. KALRA.
KILEY. LACKEY LEVINE YOU MOAN.
LOW MAIN SHINE MATHIS MAYES
MCCARTY MEDINA MELENDEZ
MULLIN. MASUCCI KNOW THE AREA
AND. OBERNOLTE O'DONNELL
PATTERSON QUIRK QUIRK SILVA. RAY
SAYS RODRIGUEZ.
RUBIO SOLACE SANTIAGO SYNAR'S
STONE. THEIR MEN'S
TEAM BOTH HELL.
WALDRON WEBER. WOULD MISTER
SPEAKER
MEMBERS A QUORUM IS PRESENT.
MEMBERS A QUORUM IS PRESENT IN
THE ASSEMBLY.
WE ASK OUR GUESTS AND VISITORS
IN THE REAR OF THE CHAMBER.
AND IN THE GALLERY.
PLEASE STAND FOR THE PRAYER.
THE DAY'S PRAYER. WILL BE
OFFERED BY OUR ASSEMBLY CHAPLAIN
THE REVEREND BOB WELSH TOUGH
RIVER DOES TO.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN A MOMENT OF
REFLECTION.
LAST EVENING MY WIFE PATTY AND I
THOROUGHLY ENJOYED WATCHING THE
GOLDEN GLOBE AWARDS.
THE MESSAGE SHARED THROUGHOUT
WAS ONE LONG OVERDUE.
THE EVENING'S CRESCENDO WAS
WITHOUT DOUBT OPRAH WINFREY
RECEIVING THE CECIL B. DEMILLE
AWARD FOR EXCELLENCE.
AS FAR AS PADDING AYE WERE
CONCERNED. THE ORGANIZERS FOR
THIS EVENT WOULD HAVE DONE WELL
TO CLOSE WITH OPRAH.
FOR THE UNDENIABLE TRUTH THAT
SHE SHARED. WAS THE INSPIRATION
WE ALL NEEDED TO HEAR.
OPRAH SHARED THE STORY OF VC
TAYLOR. WHO WAS KIDNAPPED AND
RAPED BY SIX POINT MAN IN
ALABAMA IN NINETEEN FORTY FOUR?
SHE DIE TEN DAYS BEFORE THE
TAPING OF THE GOLDEN GLOBES JUST
DAYS BEFORE HER NINETY EIGHTH
BIRTHDAY.
OPRAH SAID.
JUSTICE WAS NOT AN OPTION IN THE
AIR IN THE ERA OF JIM CROW. THE
MEN WHO TRIED TO DESTROY HER.
WE'RE NEVER PROSECUTED.
BUT ALL OF US HERE TODAY WE KNOW
THAT JUSTICE FOR ALL WHO HAVE
BEEN DOING TO THE SILENCE IS
LONG OVERDUE.
OPRAH CLOSE RALLYING ALL WHO
VALUE HUMAN DECENCY.
TO CONTINUE TO AS SHE SAID.
TAKE US TO A TIME WHEN NOBODY
HAS TO SAY NEED TO AGAIN.
LET US CONTINUE TO WORK TOWARDS
JUST SUCH A TIME WHEN WE CAN
LIVE RESPECTING AND CHERISHING.
OUR SHARED HUMAN DIGNITY.
NOW MORE MEET UP.
WITH KINDNESS AND GRATITUDE
BEYOND WORDS.
THANK YOU REVEREND WE ASK OUR
GUESTS AND VISITORS TO REMAIN
STANDING. AND JOIN US FOR THE
FLAG SALUTE PLEASE JOIN
ASSEMBLYMEMBER THURMAN. AS HE
LEADS US IN THE PLEDGE.
MR THURMOND.
I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG.
THANK YOU MAY BE SEATED.
REALLY OF THE PREVIOUS DAY'S
JOURNAL. ASSEMBLY CHAMBER
SACRAMENTO MONDAY NOVEMBER
TWENTY SEVEN TWENTY SEVENTEEN
PURSUANT TO THE PROVISIONS OF
JOINT WELL FIFTY NINE THE
FOLLOWING ASSEMBLY JOURNAL FOR
THE TWENTY SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN
REGULAR SESSION WAS PRINTED. ALL
WAS AN INTERN RECESS.
THE FOLLOWING COMMUNICATION WAS
PRESENTED BY THE SPEAKER IN
ORDER PENDANT IN THE TREASURER
CALDERONE MOVES.
AND MISTER DALLI SECONDS BUT THE
READING OF THE PREVIOUS DAY'S
JOURNAL BE DISPENSED WITH.
PRESENTATIONS UP PETITIONS THERE
ARE NINE.
INTRODUCTION A REFERENCE OF
BILLS WILL BE DEFERRED.
REPORTS OF COMMITTEES WILL BE
DEAN RADIN AMENDMENTS DEEMED
ADOPTED.
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR THERE
ARE NINE.
MESSAGES FROM THE SENATE.
THERE ARE NINE MOVING TWO
MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS.
THE ABSENCE IS FOR THE DAY.
FOR FUNERAL A DEATH IN THE
FAMILY ASSEMBLYMEMBER MIKE
GIPSON.
MR CALLED AROUND YOU ARE
RECOGNIZE FEAR PROCEDURAL MOTION
SIR THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND ASSEMBLY WILL ONE
EIGHTEEN I A TO ALLOW
ASSEMBLYMEMBER COOLEY TO HAVE
GAS. AND PHOTOGRAPHERS ON THE
FLOOR TODAY.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER ALL ALL I ALSO REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT SUSPEND
ASSEMBLY WILL FORTY FIVE POINT
FIVE TO ALLOW.
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS DAVID CHIU THE
SPEAKER RAY AS TING RODRIGUEZ
STEINORTH CUNNINGHAM EGGMAN AND
WEBER TO SPEAK ON AN ADJOURNMENT
AND MEMORY TODAY.
WITHOUT OBJECTION AGAINST SUCH
SHALL BE THE ORDER THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER OF ACROSS
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO SPEND
ASSEMBLY BILL FIFTY SIX. TO
ALLOW THE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE TO
NOTICE THE FOLLOWING BILLS FOR
THE JANUARY SEVENTEEN HEARING.
AB TO ANYONE SOLACE PENNY
REFERRAL FROM THE LABOR AND
EMPLOYMENT COMMITTEE AB TWELVE
FORTY EIGHT GARCIA PENDING RIVER
FOR A FROM THE EDUCATION
COMMITTEE. AND AB FIFTEEN TWENTY
SIX KALRA PENDING RE REFERRAL
FROM THE BANKING FINANCE
COMMITTEE.
WITHOUT OBJECTION AGAINST SUCH
SHALL BE THE ORDER. AT THEIR
REQUEST OF THE OTHER PLEASE
REMOVE ITEM EIGHT FOUR AB
SIXTEEN SIXTY ONE LOW MOAN FROM
THE INACTIVE FILE.
THE CLERK WILL NOTE
MEMBERS WE HAVE GUESTS WITH US
IN THE ASSEMBLY TODAY MEMBERS.
PLEASE GIVE YOUR ATTENTION TO
MISTER COOLEY.
MR COOLEY YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
FROM MY GUESTS ON THE FLOOR THE
ASSEMBLY MISTER COOLEY.
YES.
COLLEAGUES ARE RESPECT MASTER
ATTENTION AS WE HONOR THE.
ROLE OF WOMEN IN LEADERSHIP IN
CALIFORNIA THIS MORNING.
Y. MARKING A VERY SIGNIFICANT
OCCASION.
SO I THANK YOU FOR YOUR PRESENCE
HERE AND FOR YOUR. JOIN IN WITH
ME IN THIS MOMENT.
MR SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I RISE
TODAY TO HONOR PAMELA HEMAN.
ON THE OCCASION OF HER
RETIREMENT.
AS EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
LEADERSHIP CALIFORNIA.
AN ORGANIZATION SHE SPENT TWENTY
SIX YEARS SO MORE THAN A QUARTER
CENTURY
GIVING LEADERSHIP TO.
AND I CAN ATTEST THAT THE ROLE
OF WOMEN IN OUR STATE GOVERNMENT
HAS VASTLY CHANGE OVER THAT
QUARTER CENTURY OF TIME.
AND MANY OF YOU HERE OR.
REFLECT THAT.
I AM ALSO PLEASED TO WELCOME
HERE ON TO OUR ASSEMBLY FLOOR.
HER STEP DAUGHTER CAROLINE
HUMAN.
AND A COLLEAGUE HAROLD QUj LEE
AND PAULA MARCH TWO COLLEAGUES.
A PALL OF BEING.
PAMELA'S CHILDHOOD FRIEND.
AND A PAST PRESENT ALSO
VIEWERSHIP CALIFORNIA.
IN ADDITION THERE'S A GROUP OF
OVER TWENTY COLLEAGUES FRIENDS
AND LEADERSHIP JOINING US IN THE
UPPER GALLERY.
AND THERE THEY ARE HERE TODAY ON
BEHALF OF THE MORE THAN SIXTEEN
HUNDRED WOMEN.
WHO OVER THE LIFE THIS
ORGANIZATION?
HAVE BEEN A PART OF.
THIS ORGANIZATIONS GROWTH OF
LEADERSHIP
IN CALIFORNIA
SO PLEASE JOIN ME A WELCOME ME
PAMELA R. GASSED AND THOSE IN
THE CHAMBERS.
ANOTHER TO HAVE YOU HERE.
YEAH.
I AM THE LAWYER SORT COURSE THIS
GOES ON.
PAMELA WAS INITIALLY RECRUITED
AS A MEMBER OF THE INAUGURAL
CLASS OF LEADERSHIP CALIFORNIA.
CALIFORNIA'S ISSUES.
AND TRENDS PROGRAM.
LEADERSHIP CALIFORNIA'S
ORGANIZATION MORE THAN.
.
SIX HER WOMEN IN THIS ROLE.
SHE WAS QUICKLY RECOGNIZED FOR
HER EXPERTISE IN ASSOCIATION
MANAGEMENT.
AND WAS HIRED OF BY LEADERSHIP
CALIFORNIA FULL TIME AFTER SHE
COMPUTER THAT CLASS IN THAT
INAUGURAL YEAR.
IN NINETEEN NINETY NINE SHE
BECAME THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
LEADERSHIP CALIFORNIA.
IN THIS ROLE SHE HAS WORKED
DILIGENTLY ACROSS THE YEARS TO
ADVANCE YOUR ASSERTIONS MISSION.
TO INCREASE THE REPRESENTATION
AND ENFORCE OF WOMEN LEADERS
ACROSS THE STATE.
IN.
ALL MANNER OF RULES.
DURING HER TENURE THE
ORGANIZATIONS GROWN. AND
EXPANDED ITS OUTREACH INCLUDE
THE ESTABLISHMENT OF.
THE LEADERSHIP CALIFORNIA GOES
TO WASHINGTON DC PROGRAM.
SHE HAS BEEN INSTRUMENTAL
EXTENDED THE ORGANIZATIONS
INTERNATIONAL INFLUENCE BY
ENSURING THAT LEADERSHIP
CALIFORNIA WOMEN WELCOME
DELEGATIONS TO THE STATE
CAPITOL.
AND BY COLLABORATING AND OTHER
RULES OF THE UNITED STATES STATE
DEPARTMENT.
PAM WAS GENERAL WIDELY RESPECTED
AND ADMIRED BY ALL WHO HAVE HAD
THE OPTION TO WORK WITH HER.
AND ON BEHALF OF THIS BODY I AM
HONORED TO COMMEND HER FOR HER.
INCREDIBLE COMMITMENT TO
EMPOWERING.
APPEARING WHEN TO TAKE A
LEADERSHIP ROLES.
ACROSS THE STATE AND I WISH HER
CONTINUED SUCCESS AND I HAVE A
RESOLUTION TO COMMANDER ON THIS
OCCASION FOR. RETIREMENT TO
ENTER HER FOR TODAY.
MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING TO
BUSINESS ON THE DAILY FILE. IN.
RECONSIDERATION ITEM SEVENTY
EIGHT SEVENTY NINE EIGHTY AND
EIGHTY ONE WILL BE CONTINUE.
WE ARE MOVING TO ASSEMBLY THIRD
READING.
THIS IS
FILE ANDNUMBER EIGHTY TWO FOR
THE PURPOSES OF AMENDMENT.
THE CLERK WILL READ WITH
AMENDMENTS.
THAT'S UNABLE EIGHTY NINE WITH
AMENDMENTS BY SOMETHING THAT
REMARKS DOWN.
MR STONE ON THE AMENDMENTS.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
THESE AMENDMENTS.
CLARIFY THIS BILL THEY MOVE THE
PROVISIONS SET OF IN A NEW
SECTION AS IT WAS PUT IT INTO AN
EXISTING SECTION OF LAW. AND
STREAMLINED THE PROVISIONS OF
THIS BILL IN ORDER TO TRY AND
ROOTS OF THE OPPOSITION AYE
AFTER THIS BILL BE AMENDED THAT
TO BE SENT OUT TO PRINT AND PUT
BACK ON FILE.
THANK YOU MISTRESS DOWN.
SEEING NO SKETCHER DEBATE
WITHOUT OBJECTION WE MAY TAKE A
VOICE VOTE ON THESE AMENDMENTS
ALL THOSE IN FAVOR SAY AYE. AYE
OPPOSED SAY NAY.
THE AYES HAVE IT THE AMENDMENTS
ARE ADOPTED BILLS OUT TO PRINT
AND BACK ON FILE.
VIOLATED NUMBER EIGHTY THREE.
ALSO FOR THE PURPOSE OF
AMENDMENTS.
IT'S FILE AND NUMBER EIGHTY
THREE AB FIFTEEN SEVENTY SIX FOR
THE PURPOSE OF AMENDMENTS
COVERAGE WITH AMENDMENTS.
ASSEMBLY BILL FIFTEEN SEVENTY
SIX WITH THE MEMONS BY FAMILY
MEMBER LEVINE.
MR LEVINE ON THE MEMBERS THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER OF AMENDMENTS
AT THE DESK FOR THE TOWN
PROTECTION ACT OF TWENTY
EIGHTEEN WHICH WILL PROVIDE
TRAINING TO HELP ARTISTS IN THE
ENTERTAINMENT INDUSTRY.
IDENTIFYING PROTECT THEMSELVES
AGAINST SEXUAL HARASSMENT WILL
PREVENT PROVIDING THEM WITH
APPROPRIATE HOLD STANDARDS
ASPIRIN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MR LEVINE.
WITHOUT OBJECTION WE MAY TAKE A
VOICE HEARD ON THESE AMENDMENTS
ALL THOSE IN FAVOR SAY AYE.
AYE OPPOSED SAY NAY.
THE AYES HAVE IT THE AMENDMENTS
ARE ADOPTED BILLS OUT TO PRINT.
IN BACK ON FILE.
PURSUANT TO ASSEMBLY RULE
SEVENTY SEVEN POINT TWO. I AM
REFERRING AB FIFTEEN SEVENTY SIX
BY MISTER LEVIN TO THE LABOR.
AND EMPLOYMENT COMMITTEE
EVERS WHERE FILE ITEM NUMBER
EIGHTY FOUR.
THIS FILE ITEM NUMBER EIGHTY
FOUR ACR ONE FORTY ONE BY DR
CHAN.
THE CLERK READ.
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
ONE FORTY ONE BY SOMETHING
MEMBER CHEN RELATIVE TO
CALIFORNIA FITNESS WE.
MEMBERS.
PLEASE GIVE DOCTOR CHEN YOUR
ATTENTION DOCTOR CHEN ON THE
RESOLUTION.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I'M
HERE TODAY TO PRESENT ACR ONE
FOUR ONE.
ACR ONE FOUR ONE WILL RECOGNIZE
THE WEEK A GENEROUS SEVEN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN AS CALIFORNIA FITNESS
WEEK.
CALIFORNIA RANKS FORTY SEVENTH
THE NATION AN ADULT OBESITY.
CURRENT OBESITY RATES IN
CALIFORNIA OR AT TWENTY FIVE
PERCENT OFF FROM EIGHTY PERCENT
TWO THOUSAND AND NINE PERCENT.
IN NINETEEN NINETY.
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
EDUCATION STATES THAT OVER FIFTY
PERCENT OF CALIFORNIA'S CHILDREN
ARE NOT PHYSICALLY FIT.
THE CENTER FOR DISEASE CONTROL
AND PREVENTION SAYS THAT ALMOST
TWO THIRDS OF ALL YOU.
AND CONSUME YOU S. AT LEAST ONE
SUGAR SWEETENED BEVERAGE A DAY.
EXERCISING FITNESS ACTIVITIES
ARE EXCELLENT WASTE LOWER RISK
OF HEART DISEASE AND DIABETES.
PREVENT BONE LOSS AND INCREASED
RISK OF SOME CANCERS.
I THINK THE REALLY IMPORTANT
THAT WE CONTINUE TO EDUCATE THE
YOUTH.
AND ADULTS ON THE HARMFUL
EFFECTS AND PROPER NUTRITION AND
ACTIVITY.
I MYSELF HAVE BEEN IN PHYSICAL
ACTIVITY FITNESS FOR MY ENTIRE
ADULT LIFE. HOW THE FORMER
MEMBER OF THE U. S. KICK BOXING
TEAM WHICH HELPED GIVE ME GOOD
INITIATIVES DIRECTION? AND ALSO
SOME HARD WORK TO MAKE SURE THAT
ARE PHYSICALLY FIT.
IN ITSELF WAS A GOOD ATTEMPT TO
MAKE SURE I CAN HAVE MY.
FRESHMAN FIFTEEN.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND I
RESPECT THE ASKER AYE VOTE.
I ALSO LIKE TO OPEN THE FIRST
WILL CALL FOR CO AUTHORS.
THANK YOU DOCTOR CHEN.
MISTER GALLAGHER MAY LIKE TO
COMMENT ON THAT LAST REFERENCE.
MISTER SPEAKER QUESTION THE
AUTHOR.
WITHOUT OBJECTION.
I HAVE A COUPLE QUESTIONS
ACTUALLY WHAT IS THIS YOUR FIRST
BILL SIR.
THIS.
BUT I'M I'M GLAD YOU PICK
SOMETHING VERY.
SUBSTANTIVE THAT IS THAT WE
SHOULD ALL BE FOCUSED ON WHICH
IS OUR OWN HEALTH AND WELL
BEING.
.
I ALSO DID YOU BRING UP THIS
BILL JUST SO YOU COULD TALK
ABOUT YOU BEING ON THE U. S.
KICK BOXING TEAM.
I THOUGHT THAT WOULD BE HELP OF
AS A WAVE TO GIVE MORE MY BILLS
PASSES NO MY PHYSICAL PROWESS.
INDEED IN IS THIS BECAUSE I
DIDN'T SHOW UP TO YOUR BOOT
CAMP.
WHY MY SUGGESTION IS YOUR ONE OF
MY COLLEAGUES IN WHICH I CARE
FOR THE MOST?
AND YOUR LACK OF PHYSICAL
FITNESS IS.
SO I THINK.
PAUL WING.
BUT I WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
THERE'S STILL HOPE FOR YOU IT.
WE WILL MAKE SURE THAT YOU EAT
WELL. EXERCISE HEALTHY SO THAT
MANY MORE PEOPLE CAN ENJOY YOUR
PUBLIC POLICY LEGISLATION.
WELL WHAT WITHOUT ANY FURTHER.
WITHOUT ANY FURTHER QUESTIONS
THAT MISTER SPEAKER IT THANK YOU
FOR BRINGING THIS FOR MR CHECK I
AM GAINING ON THE MISTER CHEN
PLAN THIS YEAR IN FACT I WENT TO
THE GYM THIS MORNING.
I HAVE YOU KNOW MISTER CHAN SO
THANK YOU AT. SO LET THIS BE THE
YEAR OF HEALTH.
IT PROSPERITY AND I.
THANK YOU MISS THANK YOU MISTER
CHEN FOR BRINGING THIS FOR I'M
SORRY MUST WAS TO CALL YOU BY
YOUR FIRST NAME.
IT'S.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR KIND
WORDS.
BY THE WAVES DOCTOR CHEN.
COME.
ALSO WHEN IT COMES TO EXERCISE
IT'S MORE THAN JUST USING HER
BICEPS PUT BEER IN YOUR MOUTH.
THANK YOU FOR THE CLARIFICATION
DOCTOR CHEN.
SEEING NO OTHER DISCUSSION.
OUR DEBATE ON THE RESOLUTION.
DR CHEN'S ASKING THAT THE FIRST
ROLE BE OPEN FOR CO AUTHORS ON
THE RESOLUTION MEMBERS THIS IS
FOR A CO AUTHORS. ON THE
RESOLUTION CARPOOL UP THERE ALL.
THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS MEMBERS.
MEMBERS THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS.
CLARK WILL.
CLOSE THE ROLE THERE ARE SIXTY
NINE CO AUTHORS ADDED ON THE
RESOLUTION WITHOUT OBJECTION WE
MAY TAKE A VOICE VOTE. ON THE
RESOLUTION ALL THOSE IN FAVOR
SAY AYE.
I.
ALL THOSE IN FAVOR SAY AYE.
OPPOSED SAY NAY.
YEAH I'D HAVE IT THE RESOLUTION
IS ADOPTED.
AND DOCTOR CHEN I BELIEVE YOU
HAVE GAS IN THE CHAMBER TODAY.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER. UP
MEMBERS ELECTED PRODUCED TO YOU
MARK AND ANDY BELL.
MARTIN AND YOU'RE SUCCESSFUL
HUSBAND WIFE TEAM WHO TOOK IT
INNOVATIVE WEIGHTLIFTING DEVICE
CALLED THE SLING SHOT. FROM A
SINGLE CAR GARAGE OPERATION AND
BUILT IT. INTO A MULTI MILLION
DOLLAR INDUSTRY I MYSELF I USE A
SLING SHOT IT'S BEEN GREAT TO
MAKE SURE THAT I HAVE A PROPER
BENCH PRESS TECHNIQUE I HIGHLY
RECOMMEND IT. AND HELP YOU
PREVENT THE FRESHMAN FIFTEEN IN
A CAN DO THE SAME FOR YOU.
THEY OWN THE SUPER TRAINING GYM
IN WEST SACRAMENTO WHICH HAS
BECOME A DESTINATION FOR ALL
ATHLETES FROM ALL OVER THE
WORLD.
AS OPEN SO EVERYONE.
WITHOUT ANY CHARGE WHICH ALSO
INCLUDES YOU MEMBERS.
THEY PUBLISHED THE ONLY POWER
LIFTING MAGAZINE IN THE WORLD
POWER MAGAZINE AND MARCOS APART
CAST A PODCAST.
THAT RIDLEY RANKS IN THE TOP TEN
ON I TUNES AND FEATURES TOP
ATHLETES FITNESS PERSONALITIES
AND NUTRITION EXPERTS FROM ALL
AROUND THE WORLD.
NO MARK IS KNOWN FOR HIS
PHYSICAL PROWESS IS
STRENGTHENING A POWERLIFTING
ATHLETE.
BUT WHEN THE BEST THINGS ABOUT.
MISTER MARTIN BELL IS AT AN
EARLY AGE HE WAS DIAGNOSED WITH
A LEARNING DISABILITY AND
DESPITE ALL THE TRIALS AND
TRIBULATIONS HIM SHE HAD TO
FACE.
HE'S OVERCOME THAT HE'S ABLE TO
MEN PORT LITERATE THOUSANDS OF
STUDENTS THOUSANDS OF YOU NOT
ONLY AN AREA BUSINESS BUT ALSO A
FITNESS.
MARK OWNER THANK YOU FOR
INSPIRING ALL OF US TO IMPROVE
OUR HUMAN CONDITION.
DESPITE ALL OBSTACLES.
AND TAKING FOR TEACHING US HOW
IN YOUR OWN WORDS HOW BE JACKED
IN TEN.
ON BEHALF OF MY COLLEAGUES YOU
WANT TO THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE
ALSO ALSO WANNA SHARE SOME
REALLY FASCINATING.
TICKETS AND INFORMATION FROM HIS
POWER LIFTING.
HE'S ABLE TO.
THAT'S WHAT I THOUSAND EIGHTY
POUNDS.
HE'S ABLE TO BENCH PRESS EIGHT
HUNDRED FIFTY FOUR POUNDS.
AND SEVEN HUNDRED SIXTY SIX
POUNDS ON THE DEADLIFTS.
TO PUT THAT IN PERSPECTIVE TO
REPEAT A THOUSAND EIGHTY POUNDS
THAT'S ABOUT FOR MEAT AND ABOUT
A HUNDRED FROM MY.
ESTEEMED COLLEAGUE FROM
CAMPBELL.
SO WITHOUT FURTHER THANK YOU FOR
BEING HERE AND WHISTLES WARMLY
WELCOME.
AND HE AND MARK BELL
AND MEMBERS FILE ITEMS EIGHTY
SIX THROUGH EIGHTY EIGHT HOUSE
AND RETAIN.
MEMBERS IF WE COULD GET YOUR
SOLEMN ATTENTION WE ARE MOVING
NOW TO ANNOUNCEMENTS AND ADJOURN
MEN'S IN MEMORY.
MEMBERS HAVE YOU'LL PLEASE TAKE
YOUR SEATS
SPECTRALLY.
THE FOLLOWING MEMBERS WERE
GRANTED PRIOR PERMISSION TO
SPEAK ON A GERMAN IN MEMORY.
MISTER DAVID CHIU.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZE FREER GERMANY
MEMORY SIR.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
MEMBERS TODAY I RISE TO ADJOURN
IN MEMORY OF SAN FRANCISCO MAYOR
EDWIN LEE.
WHO PASSED AWAY SUDDENLY ON
DECEMBER TWELFTH TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN?
I MET ADLAI YEARS BEFORE WE
SERVE TOGETHER IS ELECTED
OFFICIALS.
BEFORE HE WORKED IN GOVERNMENT.
HE WAS A CIVIL RIGHTS ADVOCATE.
REPRESENTING LOW INCOME
CHINATOWN TENANTS IN FIGHTING
EVICTIONS.
HE THEN ENTERED SO CITY
GOVERNMENT.
SERVING IN NUMEROUS LEADERSHIP
POSITIONS AS THE HEAD OF OUR
CITY'S HUMAN RIGHTS COMMISSION.
THE HEAD EVER CITIES PURCHASING.
THE DIRECTOR OF OUR PUBLIC WORKS
AND AS OUR CITY ADMINISTRATOR.
ED WAS THE GO TO GUY WHEN YOU
NEEDED SOMETHING TO GET DONE IN
OUR CITY BUREAUCRACY.
THE GUY WHO WOULD DELIVER
RESULTS QUIETLY. WITH A SMILE
AND WITHOUT EGO.
WHEN MAYOR GAVIN NEWSOM WAS
ELECTED LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR.
I WAS PROUD TO SUPPORT HIS
ASCENSION TO BECOME OUR INTER.
AS HE MADE HISTORY AS THE FIRST
CHINESE AMERICAN MAYOR OF SAN
FRANCISCO.
AS PRESIDENT OF THE BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS I HAD THE HONOR OF
WORKING ALONGSIDE HIM FOR YEARS.
AS WE TACKLE JOB CREATION DURING
THE GREAT RECESSION.
BALLOTS NUMEROUS BUDGETS
AND ADDRESSED OUR CITY AND OUR
STATE'S HOUSING CRISIS.
MARILEE WAS KNOWN FOR WORKING
TIRELESSLY FOCUSED ON BRINGING
PEOPLE TOGETHER. TO GET THINGS
DONE.
ON A PERSONAL NOTE.
I WAS ALWAYS STRUCK BY ED'S
COMPASSION.
HIS KINDNESS.
AND HIS CORNY SENSE OF HUMOR.
AND HE LEAVES BEHIND LEGACY OF
LEADING WITH TRUE CIVILITY.
A QUALITY THAT IS OFTEN SO
MISSING IN OUR POLITICS.
OUR PRAYERS GO TO HIS FAMILY
VERTICALLY TO HIS WIFE AND HIS
DAUGHTERS.
WE WILL ALL MISS HIM.
I WILL MISS R. MAYOR.
I WILL MISS MY FRIEND.
SUDDENLY.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND MR
TANK YOU ARE ALSO RECOGNIZE.
THEY CAN SPEAK ALSO WATER JOIN
MY SAN FRANCISCO COLLEAGUE AND.
IT ATTORNEY MEMORY OF OUR MAYOR
ED LEE.
LIKEMY COLLEAGUE FROM THE WEST
SIDE OF SAN FRANCISCO.
WE'VE ALSO BEEN ABLE TO WORK
WITH MERELY FOR A NUMBER OF
YEARS.
HE AND I BOTH WORKED AT THE
ASIAN LAW CAUCUS AT DIFFERENT
TIMES.
BUT THE GOALS OF THAT
ORGANIZATION WHICH WERE REALLY
TO.
DEFEND THE CIVIL RIGHTS
OF ASIAN AMERICANS WHO WERE
DISENFRANCHISED.
PRIMARILY PEOPLE WHO WORK IN
SWEATSHOPS PEOPLE WHO WERE
TENANTS IN THAT SORROWS IN
CHINATOWN PEOPLE WHO. WERE
UNDOCUMENTED IMMIGRANTS TRYING
TO FIND THEIR POWER AND THEIR
WAY. INTO THE AMERICAN DREAM.
THOSE WERE THE PEOPLE THAT THE
ORGANIZATIONS SERVED AND THOSE
ARE THE PEOPLE. THAT ARE MAYOR
CONTINUE TO FIGHT FOR AS HE.
DECIDED TO MOVE INTO SAN
FRANCISCO CITY GOVERNMENT AND
THAT ULTIMATELY BE THE FIRST
CHINESE AMERICAN FIRST ASIAN
AMERICAN. MAYOR IN OUR CITY'S
HISTORY.
JUST TO GIVE YOU ALL A SENSE OF
THE SYMBOLISM.
CHARLIE THE CHINESE AMERICAN
POPULATION FIRST STARTED COMING
TO SAN FRANCISCO IN THE MID
EIGHTEEN HUNDREDS TO HELP. BUILD
THE TRANSCONTINENTAL RAILROAD.
AND OUR POPULATION AYE AYE TIMES
HAD A.
HAD SOME WHAT ABOUT A TOUGH
TIME IN SAN FRANCISCO'S VERY
SEGREGATED AND THERE'S A LOT OF
RACISM SO FOR YEARS AND YEARS
AND YEARS THE COMMUNITY. HAD
ALWAYS WANTED TO.
FIND ITS WAY INTO CITY HALL UP
MY COLLEAGUE FROM THE WEST SIDE
WAS THE FIRST CHINESE AMERICAN
TO ASCEND TO THE PRESIDENCY OF
THE. BOARD OF SUPERVISORS AND WE
FINALLY BROKE THE LAST GLASS
CEILING WHEN.
MAYOR ED LEE BECAME THE FIRST
CHINESE AMERICAN MAYOR IN THE
CITY'S HISTORY AFTER HUNDRED AND
FIFTY YEARS OF BEING IN. SAN
FRANCISCO
AND AS YOU ALL KNOW I I'VE COME
TO APPRECIATE THE SYMBOLISM SAN
FRANCISCO HAS NOT JUST IN. ON
THE BAY AREA BUT REALLY ALL
AROUND NORTHERN CALIFORNIA HOW
IMPORTANT IT IS IN TERMS OF.
PRESENTATION
SO.
TODAY I'M VERY SOUND.
BUT ALSO VERY PROUD OF ALL THE
ACCOMPLISHMENTS THAT MERELY WAS
ABLE TO ACCOMPLISH. BUT VERY SAD
THAT HE HAS LEFT US WAY TOO SOON
AT THE YOUNG AGE OF SIXTY FIVE.
THANK IMAGE TANK.
WORK MISTER MERCER CHIEF YOU TO
OUR RECOGNIZE.
I MUCH I JUST WANT TO JOIN MY.
TWO COLLEAGUES FROM SAN
FRANCISCO TO. MAKE SURE THAT
EVERYONE KNEW THAT MAYOR ED LEE
REALLY TOUCHED THE LIVES OF SO
MANY PEOPLE OUTSIDE OF SAM CISCO
OUTSIDE OF THE BAY AREA. I WAS A
YOUNG COLLEGE STUDENT WHEN I WAS
AN INTERN AT THE ASIAN LAW
CAUCUS IN THEIR GENERATIONS OF.
A ACTIVISTS AND. A COMMUNITY
LEADERS THAT CAME OUT OF THE THE
ASIAN LAW CAUCUS AND ED LEE WAS
ALWAYS AN INSPIRATION TO MYSELF
AS SO MANY PEOPLE.
LIKE.
MY COLLEAGUE FROM WEST SAM
CISCO INDICATED A BEFORE HE WAS
MAYOR BEFORE HE SERVED IN.
FOR THE CITY OF SAN CISCO HE
WAS A RIGHTEOUS HOUSING RIGHTS
ATTORNEY HE WAS ORGANIZING AND
ADVOCATING AND FIGHTING FOR ALL
THE LOW INCOME TENANTS IN
CHINATOWN. AND THAT WAS WHEN I
WAS IN A A AND TURNED AT THE
ASIAN LAW CAUCUS AND I I WAS SO
INSPIRED BY HIS WORK THAT I
DECIDED TO FOLLOW IN HIS
FOOTSTEPS.
TO.
GO TO LAW SCHOOL AND TO BECOME
AN ADVOCATE FOR MY COMMUNITY SO
I WANTED TO ADD MY VOICE TO PAY
MY RESPECTS TO MAYOR ED LEE.
THANK YOU THIS MERCY ITCHY.
ESTHER CUNNINGHAM.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR
GERMAN IN MEMORY.
SPEAKER THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
I RISE TO JOURNEY MEMORY OF JOHN
ROSS JACK BUSHONG.
JACK WAS BORN ON NOVEMBER TWENTY
NINTH NINETEEN TWENTY EIGHT LOS
ANGELES CALIFORNIA YOU GREW UP
IN SANTA MONICA.
AND GRADUATED FROM THE
UNIVERSITY OF SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA NINETEEN FIFTY TWO.
A DEGREE IN POLITICAL SCIENCE
HE WENT ON TO WORK AT MERRILL
LYNCH WORRY RETIRED AS VICE
PRESIDENT.
IN NINETEEN NINETY ONE.
JACK WAS MARRIED TO HIS WIFE
LIVE A LEAP FOR THIRTY SIX YEARS
BEFORE SHE PASSED AWAY. HE LOVE
TO TRAVEL ESPECIALLY YOSEMITE
TAHOE.
AND EUROPE WITH THE SPECIAL OF
SCOTLAND.
HE WAS AN EAGLE SCOUT INVOLVED
THE BOY SCOUTS IS ENTIRE LIFE
AND WAS A SEASON TICKET HOLDER
FOR USC FOOTBALL.
NOW HARPER.
JACK'S SURVIVED BY HIS CHILDREN
JOHN ALLEN POE SHOWING OF
TEMPLETON AND WE AND FORMER. OF
ALAMEDA. HE ADORED HIS WONDERFUL
DAUGHTER IN LAW HIS SON IN LAW
AND IS VERY PROUD OF HIS FOUR
GRANDCHILDREN.
AND HE LIVED LONG ENOUGH TO SEE.
HIS SON JOHN PUSH ON MY
PERSONAL FRIEND BE ELECTED TO
THE SAN LUIS OBISPO COUNTY BOARD
OF SUPERVISORS WARY CURRENTLY
SERVES AS CHAIR. HOW WE'RE ALL
VERY PROUD OF THAT PROUD OF JOHN
AND?
?
THANK FOR THE JACK LIVED A LONG
AND FRUITFUL LIFE THANK YOU.
IF YOU MISTER CUNNINGHAM DOCTOR
EGGMAN YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR
YOUR GERMAN A MEMORY.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I RISE
TODAY WITH A HEAVY HEART. TO
DURING A MEMORY OF OFFICER
ANDREW J. CAMEL LARRY.
HE WAS BORN IN FEBRUARY.
NINETEEN EIGHTY FOUR THE CITY OF
TRACY AND ASSEMBLY DISTRICT
THIRTEEN TO PARENTS MICHAEL AND
SHARON HE ATTENDED. MERYL WEST
HIGH SCHOOL IN TRACY.
GOT A JOB AT MCDONALDS.
MET.
AND THEN PROPOSED AND MARRIED
HIS HIGH SCHOOL SWEETHEART
ROSEANNE.
AFTER HIGH SCHOOL HE WENT ON AND
BECAME A.
WORK FOR CLARK PEST CONTROL.
BUT ALWAYS HAD A DREAM OF OF
BEING.
A FIRST RESPONDER BEING.
AN OFFICER OF THE LAW OF HELPING
PEOPLE.
AND HE FINALLY GOT THAT DREAM
WENT TO THE ACADEMY IN TWO
THOUSAND SIXTEEN AND GRADUATED
MARCH THIRD NINETEEN.
TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN.
A.
ON CHRISTMAS EVE.
HE WAS OUT.
PATROL.
WELL WE WERE ALL ENJOYING OUR
FAMILIES.
FIRST RESPONDERS ARE OUT THERE
RISKING THEIR LIVES FOR US.
AND AS HE WAS PARKED ON THE SIDE
THE ROAD WITH HIS.
PARTNER READING SOME THINGS UP
SIMPLY DRIVING A HUNDRED AND
TWENTY MILES AN HOUR.
QUESTION THE BACK TO THEIR CAR.
KILLING HIM.
HE NEVER CAME HOME FROM THAT
SHIFT.
AND HE LEAVES BEHIND.
HIS WIFE ROSANNA.
THREE WONDERFUL CHILDREN.
ELIZABETH TWELVE.
ANDREW JUNIOR.
SIX
AND YOUNG WRITER ONLY TO.
HE ALSO BELIEVES BEHIND HIS BOTH
HIS FATHER MICHAEL HIS MOTHER
SHARON HIS STEPMOTHER CATE HIS
BROTHER MATTHEW AND HIS SISTER
ASHLEY.
PLEASE JOIN ME.
AND ADJOURNING IN HIS MEMORY.
THE DOCTOR EGGMAN.
DOCTOR WEBER.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZE FEAR GERMANY
MEMORY.
THANK YOU MR SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS.
I RISE THIS AFTERNOON
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATIVE BLACK CAUCUS AND.
ONE OF OUR MEMBERS FROM
HUNTINGTON BEACH.
TO TALK ABOUT THE AND ASK US TO
ADJOURN IN MEMORY. OF DOCTOR
JOSEPH FELT QUITE.
A RESIDENT OF IRVINE PASSED
AWAY.
TRYING TO VISIT FAMILY IN SAINT
LOUIS FOR THANKSGIVING ON
NOVEMBER TWENTY FIRST.
OF OF THIS LAST YEAR AT THE AGE
OF EIGHTY FOUR.
IN ADDITION TO THAT I RISE ON MY
OWN BEHALF BECAUSE MISTER WHITE
WAS A FRIEND.
COLLEAGUES AND A MENTOR.
HE WAS BORN IN DECEMBER NINETEEN
NINETEEN THIRTY TWO IN LINCOLN
NEBRASKA.
AND WAS RAISED IN MINNEAPOLIS BY
HIS MOTHER AFTER HIS FATHER AND
MOTHER SEPARATED.
AFTER GRADUATING FROM HIGH
SCHOOL.
AND HE WORKS VERY HARD BELIEVES
IN HIGH SCHOOL AS THEY IN ONE OF
THE HOTELS IS ONE OF THE
PORTERS.
BUT HE MADE HIS WAY TO
CALIFORNIA ONCE AGAIN WORKING ON
THE TRAINS TO EARN HIS WAY
ACROSS TOWN ACROSS THE STATE'S.
PUTIN SAN FRANCISCO STATE
UNIVERSITY.
HE EARNED HIS BACHELOR'S IN HIS
MASTER'S FROM SAN FRANCISCO
STATE.
ENTER THE MILITARY INTO TWENTY
FOUR YEARS AND THEN TWENTY FOUR
MONTHS AND THEN WENT TO MICHIGAN
STATE UNIVERSITY.
DOCTOR WHITEEARNED BIG EARNED A
PHD IN PSYCHOLOGY AT MICHIGAN
STATE IN NINETEEN SIXTY ONE.
HE WAS THE FIRST AFRICAN
AMERICAN TO EVER EARNS SUCH A
DEGREE FROM MICHIGAN STATE.
AND ONLY ONE OF FIVE IN THE
NATION AT THAT TIME TO HELD A
PHD IN PSYCHOLOGY.
YOU CAME BACK TO CALIFORNIA HE
TAUGHT AT CAL STATE LONG BEACH.
HE ALSO FOUND OF THE EEL OUT
YOUR PR PROGRAM THE EQUAL
OPPORTUNITY PROGRAM TO HELP
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF YOUNG
PEOPLE IN CALIFORNIA. TO GET AN
EDUCATION.
AND EVENTUALLY BECAME THE DEAN
OF UNDERGRADUATE STUDIES AT SAN
FRANCISCO STATE.
EXAMPLE CISCO SAY HE ALSO HELPED
ESTABLISH THE BLACK STUDIES
PROGRAM WAS THE FIRST WHICH WAS
THE FIRST BLACK STUDIES PROGRAM
IN THE NATION.
AND IN NINETEEN SIXTY EIGHT
DOCTOR WHITE FOUNDED.
CO FOUNDED THE ASSOCIATION OF
BLACK PSYCHOLOGISTS THAT EXISTS
TO THIS DAY.
HE WAS WHAT WE CALL A.
SCHOLAR ACTIVISTS.
AND THOSE A FEW AND FAR BETWEEN.
THOSE WHO ACTIVELY PARTICIPATE
IN THEIR PROFESSION.
WHO DO THE WORK WRITE THE
ARTICLES AND MANY OF HIS
ARTICLES WERE FOUNDATIONAL
ARTICLES FOR THE TO STATUS MEANT
OF THE FIELD OF BLACK
PSYCHOLOGY?
WE CHALLENGE WHITE PSYCHOLOGIST
TO BASICALLY LOOK AT THE WORLD
DIFFERENTLY.
TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY
UNDERSTOOD THE CULTURE ELEMENTS
THAT EXISTED IN PEOPLE'S LIVES
THAT INFLUENCE THE KINDS OF
DECISIONS THAT WERE MADE ABOUT
INTELLIGENCE AND OPPORTUNITIES
AND CHALLENGES THAT THEY FELT.
DOCTOR WHITE WAS ON THE CUTTING
EDGE OF THAT ALONG WITH SO MANY
OTHER BLACK PSYCHOLOGIST THE FEW
THAT ACTUALLY STARTED THE BLACK
PSYCHOLOGISTS ASSOCIATION. THAT
EXISTS TO THIS DAY STRONGER THAN
EVER STILL CHALLENGING AND
WRITING AND DOING THOSE THINGS.
HE AUTHORED THREE BOOKS THAT
BAIT HIM BECOME WHAT WE CALL THE
GODFATHER OF PSYCHOLOGY.
HE ALONG WITH OTHERS WHO ARE
AUTHORED THE BOOKS THAT
BASICALLY TALKED ABOUT THE
ISSUES OF BLACK PSYCHOLOGY AND
CULTURE RELEVANCE IN THE
PSYCHOLOGICAL ANALYSIS OF
INDIVIDUALS.
IT GROUNDBREAKING WORK ON
AFRICAN AMERICAN MALES IN ISSUES
OF RAGE IN AMERICA
AND SO HE WAS REALLY ONE OF THE
ACT THE SCHOLARS WHO DID THE
WORK.
BUT MOST IMPORTANT HE ALSO
MENTORED HUNDREDS AND HUNDREDS
OF STUDENTS.
THOSE STUDENTS TO LOOK TO HIM AS
AN EXAMPLE BECAUSE HE AYE HE
CONSTANTLY BATTLE THE
INSTITUTIONS TO MAKE SURE THAT
THE IVORY TOWER REALLY WAS OPEN
TO EVERY STUDENT.
AND BASICALLY SUPPORTED ALL THE
KINDS OF WORK THAT WE DID IN
BLACK STUDIES AND CULTURE
RELEVANCE INCOME CULTURE
COMPETENCIES. THAT WAS DOCTOR
WHITE.
AND HE BECAME THE MENTOR TO
SOLVE MANY YOUNG PEOPLE THAT I'D
MEET EVERYWHERE WILL TALK ABOUT.
WHAT HE DID FOR THEM TO HELP
THEM GET INTO GRADUATE SCHOOL
HOW WE HELP THEM WITH THEIR
DOCTORAL WORK HOW HE GAVE THEM
AN OPPORTUNITY TO DO THINGS THAT
OTHERS DID NOT?
EVEN AFTER HIS RETIREMENT.
BUT CAL STATE IRVINE. HE
CONTINUED IN TO WORK WITH SO
MANY OTHER YOUNG PEOPLE IN SO
MANY INSTITUTIONS AND BECAME A
ROLE MODEL FOR ALL OF US WHO ARE
FACULTY.
TO UNDERSTAND THAT WE HAVE NOT
ONLY JUST THE OPPORTUNITY TO
TEACH
BUT WE HAVE THE RESPONSIBILITY.
TO BASICALLY BRING IN A NEW
GENERATION OF SCHOLARS WHO
LOOKED AT THE WORLD DIFFERENTLY
WHO HELP TO THOSE IN NEED AND TO
REPRESENT THE COMMUNITIES THAT
WE DID REPRESENT.
DOCTOR WHITES LEGACY
LIVES IN HIS ABILITY NOT ONLY TO
DO THE SCHOLARLY WORK.
FIGHT THESE CHALLENGES OF RACISM
THAT HE FOUGHT REGULARLY IN FACT
HE OFTEN SAID THAT ONE OF THE
THAT HE HAD. HE KNEW OF RACISM
AND HAD EXPERIENCE OF SOME OF IT
IN THE SOUTH.
BUT WAS INTERESTING HE SAID THE
BOOK HE'D NEVER EXPERIENCED THAT
MUCH RACISM UNTIL HE BECAME A
PHD.
AND REALLY BEGIN TO CHALLENGE
THE SYSTEM BECAUSE AT THAT POINT
YOU HAVE THE TOOLS TO CHAO'S THE
SYSTEM.
AND WAS AT THAT POINT HE REALIZE
OF RACISM.
WHEN HE BECAME A PROFESSOR AT
IRVINE TO CONFER EVER TO FIND A
PLACE TO LIVE THERE'S NO ONE ONE
TO RENT TO AN AFRICAN AMERICAN
EVEN THOUGH HE WAS A PHD AFRICAN
AMERICAN. BEING BROUGHT INTO THE
INSTITUTION.
SERVING IN LEADERSHIP CAPACITIES
THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
HE NEVER FORGOT FROM WHENCE HE
CAME.
I COULDN'T CONTINUE TO WORK ON
BEHALF OF YOUNG PEOPLE
EVERYWHERE.
AND SO HE LEAVES US IN SOME WAY
WITH SOME SADNESS SOME SADNESS
OBVIOUSLY UP EIGHTY FOUR YEARS.
BUT LISTEN REAL JOY THAT WE HAVE
THE CHANCE OF NO DOCTOR JOSEPH
WHITE.
A MAN OF TREMENDOUS INTEGRITY
AND LEADERSHIP WHO LOVE STUDENTS
AND WAS A MASTER TEACHER HIS
STUDENTS WOULD OFTEN TALK ABOUT
HIM THE NIGHT HUMAN LECTURES AT
NATIONAL CONFERENCES. WE REALLY
WAS ABLE TO BREAK DOWN THE
ISSUES AND HELP THE AVERAGE
PERSON UNDERSTAND THE TREMENDOUS
OF WEALTH OF IN KNOWLEDGE AND IN
IN INTELLECT THAT THE HECK.
HE LEAVES TO MOURN US AS ONE OF
THESE PIONEERS TO OPEN THE DOOR
AND I THINK THAT MOST OF THE
FOUNDERS OF THE LOVE BLACK
PSYCHOLOGISTS ASSOCIATION. ARE
DECEASED EXCEPT FOR MAYBE ONE.
HE WE SEND CONDOLENCES TO HIS
FAMILY HE HE LEAVES TO MOURN HIS
WIFE LOWERS HIS THREE DAUGHTERS
LAURIE LISA AND LEN AND EVEN
HIS FORMER WIFE IS STILL A
FRIEND MYRTLE. TO LEAVE THEM IN
HIS MEMORY THEY THEY THEY THINK
OF HIM AND THE INTERESTING THING
IS A LARA BECAME A MEANT TO YOUR
MIND WHEN SHE CAME SAN DIEGO
STATE UNIVERSITY IS ONE OF THE
WORKERS IN STUDENT AFFAIRS.
AND DOES SHE MENTORS SO MUCH
LIKE HER FATHER WORKING WITH
PEOPLE EVERYWHEREAND HE WAS
TRAVELING TO VISIT HER WHEN HE
DIED HE SHE IS NOW THE VICE
CHANCELLOR. AT THE UNIVERSITY OF
WASHINGTON ST LOUIS IN THE SAME
KIND OF LEGACY AS HER FATHER.
AFRICAN PROVERB ALWAYS TELLS US
THAT.
NO ONE EVER REALLY DIES.
I WAS LOST
UNTIL THE LAST PERSON ON EARTH.
BUT THEY ONCE IT'S ONCE KNEW
THAT PERSON NO LONGER EXIST.
BASED ON HIS WORK AS A MENTOR
AND A PROFESSOR HE WILL LIVE FOR
GENERATIONS AND GENERATIONS TO
COME.
I ASK THAT YOU JOINED THAT THIS
HOUSE TO JOIN IN MEMORY OF
DOCTOR JOSEPH WHITE.
THANK YOU DOCTOR WEBER.
MISTER SPEAKER YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR GERMAN IN
MEMORY.
THANK THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS MEMBERS I ASKED THAT WE
ADJOURN TODAYIN MEMORY OF
DENNIS CARL SALANDER A RESIDENT
OF THE CITY OF LAKEWOOD. JOINING
US TODAY TO HONOR DENNIS ARE
MEMBERS OF THE LIQUID CITY
COUNCIL. VICE MAYOR STEVE KROFT
COUNCILMEMBER ROD PIAZZA AND
COUNCIL MEMBER JEFF WOULD.
DENNIS LANDER WAS BORN IN
COMPTON AND HE IN HIS FAMILY
BECAME ORIGINAL RESIDENTS OF THE
CITY OF LAKEWOOD.
HE WAS A VIETNAM VETERAN AND THE
TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN HE WAS THE
SIX
THE THIRD ASSEMBLY DISTRICT
VETERAN OF THE YEAR.
DENNIS WROTE A POEM THAT IS
BECOMING INTRAPARTY OF THE CITY
OF LAKE WOODS VETERANS MEMORIAL.
SADLY DENNIS PASSED AWAY
NOVEMBER THE NIGHT BEFORE HE WAS
TO BE AN HONORED GUEST AT THAT
MY ANNUAL VETERAN CELEBRATION IN
THE DISTRICT.
AFTER HIS DISCHARGE FROM THE
AIRFORCE IN NINETEEN SIXTY NINE
DENNIS RETURNED TO HIS HOME IN
LAKEWOOD.
HE FIRST HAD A SUCCESSFUL CAREER
THE MOVING INDUSTRY FOLLOWED BY
A TWENTY TWO YEAR CAREER IN
WASTE MANAGEMENT.
HE IS SURVIVED BY HIS WIFE
SHELLY THEY'RE FOR CHILDREN AND
THIRTEEN GRANDCHILDREN.
HE IS ALSO SURVIVED BY HIS
FELLOW VETERANS WHO ARE VERY
MUCH PART OF HIS FAMILY.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
DURING THE MEMORY OF DENNIS
LANDER.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
MS RESTS YOUR RECOGNIZE FOR YOUR
CHAIRMAN IN MEMORY.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
TODAY I RISE.
TO ADJOURN THE MEMORY OF SAN
BERNARDINO COUNTY SHERIFF'S
DEPUTY LARRY.
LAWRENCE.
FALSELY.
LARRY PASSED AWAY ON JUNE
JANUARY SECOND TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN DUE TO INJURIES
SUFFERED DURING AN ASSAULT.
HEARD WHILE HE WAS OFF DUTY ON
NEW YEAR'S EVE.
HE WAS SEVENTY YEARS OLD.
LARRY WAS A COMMITTED A PUBLIC
SERVANT WHO DEDICATED HIS ENTIRE
LIFE TO BOTH A SYMBOL TO DENOTE
COMMUNITY. AND OUR NATION.
HE SERVED IN THE UNITED STATES
ARMY DURING THE VIETNAM WAR. AND
UPON BEING HONORABLY DISCHARGED
SERB DECEMBER TO DEAN A
COMMUNITY AS A DEPUTY SHERIFF
FOR THIRTY SIX YEARS.
THE MAJORITY OF THOSE YEARS WERE
SPENT WORKING PATROL AT CENTRAL
STATION IN SAN BERNARDINO WHERE
YOU HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO MAKE
A LASTING MARK.
ON NOT ONLY HIS PEERS
BUT THE MEMBERS OF THE COMMUNITY
WHICH HE SERVED.
LARRY AND SO MANY OTHERS IN OUR
LAW ENFORCEMENT COMMUNITY.
PUT THEMSELVES IN HARM'S WAY
EACH DAY.
AND EVERY DAY AT GREAT RISK
THROUGH TO THEMSELVES.
A SACRIFICE.
THAT WE MUST ALWAYS APPRECIATE
AND ACKNOWLEDGE.
TODAY WE STAND WITH LARRY. HIS
FAMILY. OUR SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT
AND OUR COMMUNITY.
TO MOURN HIS PASSING.
I ALSO TO PLEASE JOIN ME IN
ADJOURNING IN MEMORY OF LARRY
FALSITY.
THEY IN ISRAEL'S
IT'S RODRIGUEZ YOU ARE ALSO
RECOGNIZE ON THIS SAY I AM.
MR SPEAKER MEMBERS. ALSO RISE
TODAY TO RETURN IN MEMORY OF
SOMEBODY YOU KNOW COUNTY
SHERIFF'S DEPUTY LARRY FAL'CIE.
THIS TRAGIC INCIDENT BRINGS TO
LIGHT THAT OUR OFFICERS CAN FACE
DANGER AT EVERY TURN.
HIS FAMILY FRIENDS
FELLOW OFFICERS AND THE
COMMITTEE HAVE COME TOGETHER TO
REMEMBER AND CELEBRATE HIS
DEDICATION AND KIND SPIRIT.
AS A FATHER OF A SON WHO WAS A
DEPUTY SHERIFF I AM CONSTANTLY
REMINDED. OF THE GREAT
SACRIFICES THEY MAKE FOR US
DAILY.
I HOPE THAT JUSTICE IS FOUND ON
BEHALF DEPUTY FALSITY. WHAT WE
KEEP THE DEPARTMENT AND IS FOUND
IN OUR PRAYERS THINKING?
THANK YOU MISS RODRIGUEZ.
STEINORTH.
MISTER SPEAKER.
TODAY I ASSN WE ADJOURN IN THE
MEMORY OF A FALLEN ON FORSMAN
OFFICER.
OUR COMMUNITY GRIEVES FOR THE
LOS.
DEPUTY LAWRENCE FALL SEE WITH A
HEAVY HEART.
DEBBIE FALSE HE SERVED HIS
COUNTRY SERVICE COMMUNITY IS
ENTIRE ADULT LIFE.
AT SEVENTY YEARS OLD DEPUTY FALL
SEE SHOWED UP TO WORK AND WENT
ABOVE AND BALL BEYOND THE CALL
OF DUTY EVERY SINGLE DAY.
HE COULD HAVE RETIRED.
HE COULD HAVE LEFT THE WORK TO A
SUCCESSOR SUCCESSORS BUT HE
NEVER EVEN CONSIDERED IT.
HIS COLLEAGUES DESCRIBED HIM AS
A REMARKABLE MENTOR.
TO THE YOUNG DEPUTIES AND A
DEDICATED PARTNER.
NOW AROUND THE DEPARTMENT WHO IS
BEST KNOWN FOR HIS FLANNEL
SHIRT.
ANY STILL IT'S SILLY R.
SNAPSHOTS AND I I THINK THAT'S
ABSOLUTELY FANTASTIC AT SEVENTY
HE WAS DOING GOOFY SNAPSHOTS.
THE MOST ESPECIALLY FOR HIS KIND
AND HUMBLE ATTITUDE.
DEPUTY FOSSE MADE AN INCREDIBLE
DIFFERENCE IN OUR COMMUNITY AND
IN EVERY LIFE HE TOUCHED.
WE'VE LOST AN EXTRAORDINARY MAN.
AND I HAVE NO DOUBT THAT HIS
LEGACY WILL LAST FOR
GENERATIONS.
NOW I ALSO WOULD LIKE TO EXTEND
MY GRATITUDE TO THE SHERIFF'S
EMPLOYEE BENEFITS ASSOCIATION.
THE SALMON DINO COUNTY SHERIFF'S
DEPARTMENT.
LOMA LINDA UNIVERSITY MEDICAL
CENTER.
AND THE BRAID BYSTANDERS WHO
PREVENTED THE SUSPECT'S ESCAPE.
AND ALL OF THOSE WHO PUT THEIR
LIVES IN DANGER EVERY DAY FOR
OUR SAFETY.
COLLEAGUES PLEASE JOIN ME IN A
TURNING TODAY AND THE MEMORY OF
DEPUTY LAWRENCE BOSSY.
THEY GIVE US STEINORTH.
THANK YOU MEMBERS.
ANNOUNCEMENTS.
THE SESSION SCHEDULE IS AS
FOLLOWS.
TUESDAY JANUARY NINTH CHECK IN
SESSION. WEDNESDAY JANUARY TENTH
SECOND SESSION. THURSDAY JANUARY
ELEVENTH CHECK IN SESSION.
FRIDAY JANUARY TWELFTH FLOOR
SESSION AT NINE A. M..
ALL OTHER ITEMS REMAINING WE
PASS RETAIN ALL MOTION SHALL BE
CONTINUE. SEEING SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER BUSINESS I'M
READY TO ENTERTAIN A MOTION TO
ADJOURN.
MISH MS WALDRON MOVES AND MISTER
VALLEY SECONDS THAT THIS HOUSE
STANDS ADJOURNED UNTIL FRIDAY
JANUARY TWELFTH A NINETY M. IN
THE QUORUM CALL IS LIFTED